le courage dont elle a fait preuve
au fil des ans, c'est qu'il y a
tellement de fois qu'elle a dû
vraiment s'impliquer profondément
[Musique] [
Musique]
le couronnement
parce que j'étais une petite fille au
couronnement et j'ai agité le drapeau puis nous
avons fait une fête de rue et
je voulais  gagnez la poupée qui ressemblait à celle
du balcon, vous savez, quand elle est sur
le balcon, elle est sortie pour son 70e
anniversaire, j'ai trouvé ça vraiment touchant
qu'elle soit si petite qu'elle soit
sortie et j'ai trouvé ça adorable
quand
Diana est décédée et elle  s'est rendu compte qu'elle
devait réévaluer
sa position auprès de la communauté dans le
public et que l'on a
reconquis le pays d'une manière assez
profonde, je pense que
euh, j'ai
bien dit
[Musique]
c'était des choses comme le truc de Paddington Bay
qu'elle a fait il y a quelques mois pour  le
jubilé, ils ont fait une vidéo avec l'
ours Paddington, vous savez, une icône nationale, c'était
juste que cela prouvait qu'elle était dévouée, elle était
pleine de vie jusqu'à la toute fin, vraiment,
elle trouve toujours que c'est
vraiment amusant et enjoué et qu'elle rit
surtout quand vous la voyez comme  juin euh,
levez les gardes et faites trébucher la
couleur, elle sourit toujours pour qu'elle ait
toujours l'air d'
être une arrière-grand-mère
[Musique]
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale, elle changeait
les pneus dans le parc automobile avant d'être reine,
j'ai trouvé que c'était remarquable  ta
royauté et tu te graisses les mains
et tout le reste quand tu as
des gens qui pourraient le faire pour toi
donc c'est ce qui m'a le plus impressionné
chez elle oh il y en a trop pour les mentionner
vraiment je pense que probablement plus tard, je veux
dire que la plupart des gens sont fatigués  n'est-ce pas qu'à
65 ans 70 ans,
elle y va encore à 96 ans jusqu'à
deux jours avant sa mort
[Musique]
tu